Thomas ta sœur elle est partie
ces gens ce sont des blasphémateurs
une maladie occulte la ramener à la maison nom Thomas
Richardson une lueur d'un monde dans lequel
chaque jour de veille nous nous levons est tiré cette
île c'est notre paradis nous avons un
intrus sur notre terre et nous devons  trouve-
le tu l'as élevé ils ont vu des choses
qui es-tu il sera changé
selon l'Edit de cette terre le
service du divin n'est qu'une illusion
Dieu est douleur Dieu souffre méfiez-vous des
faux prophètes qui viennent à vous en
vêtements de brebis mais intérieurement ils  sont
des règles voraces commençons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pardonne-nous
toi